25-year-old woman named Emily let with
an abortion counselor from New Jersey
she filmed herself having an abortion
and this thing is blowing up you might
have seen it already
we're shaded a little bit just mention
story
on show
women very thirsty I'm have abortions
during
now on
at
yeah that
happen
you
%um well as obviously she was trying to
show a positive abortions or 85 C
pro-abortion shit abortion counseling I
believe
a woman's right to choose and I have no
right to tell women what to do with her
own body
but after watching this I was really
kinda conflicted
this sorta helps the cause abortion or
not because by showing something
that clinically it actually paid a go to
a little weird to me really did
what you think I mean okay like it
personally I think my very first
response when I watch this was like I
don't care
but I don't think I'm the audience or
that for the a story I
a I've never had an abortion but like
you I'm
pro-choice I have friends who have had
abortions and I don't think that I am
eating
YouTube video to understand the process
but that's me I would
research it in different ways I think if
I were faced with that
difficult but we on aggression may have
not to go into the character in a mere
I'm yeah every democrat exactly I'm not
you know but
at New my fuckin response when I saw
this video with like
you know if like it not well done
that like I think that that was my
problem shuster trying to force with the
music in my car with a positive
it's like okay it it the personal
experience yeah
it an experience that could have
positive
I'll often does have positive
ramifications in somebody's life down
the line but
with having an outpatient procedure is
like
you know something that needs violin
music behind it just you're right it
puts a bad taste in your mouth a little
bit and I think more than anything
all this video is really going to do is
gonna polarize people
if you look at where it was posted the
article where I first read it from
with on a conservative site and the
victory all in the comments section
with like 0 I mean granted she must have
known that was gonna happen
I don't blame her I think that you know
she has the right to
to make this kind of statement and
honestly maybe if she did touch one or
two young women who were like
I want to do this but I'm afraid I think
that it's gonna hurt
I think it's gonna you know ruin my life
and they want to go maybe it's not that
bad I actually do have an option
yeah I mean I well and you're totally
right about strengthening the others I
think that once this thing got posted on
Drudge then it goes to cross the right
weighing blog a spear and everyone
starts granting get it do you generally
agree with that
I mean I generally do I think I feel bad
because your I didn't get posted on a
conservative website the comments were
so hateful towards her
they said that she got pregnant on
purpose so that she could do this and
get all this attention which is just
because we love having abortion I wrote
I am NOT a look now but
right there now it really parties and
really touchy subject in like I'll try
to avoid saying that I'm pro-abortion
and say that I'm pro-choice because no
one wants the pro-abortion like yeah
abortions are us on the right but how
many people I think that like
yet it it's something that most women
use as a form of birth control because
it somehow
easier without you there to just not
think about it get laid what the fuck
ever other take care the baby it's like
woman wants to do that it can't be
comfortable
and I it is emotional for most be held
what a medical problem sometimes people
can't get pregnant after having an
abortion there's a lot of serious
consequences with that and it can be
psychologically detrimental
which is something that I think the one
the biggest reasons why didn't like this
video is because she's just so what
happy the whole time in
that's good because like you said it's
important to show girls already made the
choice
to have an abortion that it's not gonna
hurt you know it's not gonna be
as horrible as they might think it could
be and it kinda give them some
reassurance but the same time
it's kinda like almost encouraging our
way right so it sounds like you both
agree that her idea was good here but
that the way they produce this with the
music and you know her it like she was
going so far out of her way to make it
seem like it was okay
that also you know we don't see the
clinical things it will remind me of
like the death penalty
when we don't see these people being put
together I get the death penalty
anywhere
but like if we don't see it we don't
know what's going on a bike seeing her
laying there
if felt much more humid it actually was
making me rethink my position a little
bit I'm still pro-choice I mean that
kinda why my first reaction was just
like the production values are so
terrible
I feel like if it had been produced a
little bit differently
like if if she had you know edited
things a little bit differently shown
it look like you selectively edited to
only show the part where he was the most
comfortable she never once said like
okay this part is a little Inc okay I'm
I'm pass it up after it
if it had felt a little more real to me
because I will I do kind of like the
idea though that we were in that room
with her
experiencing it with her and she was
sharing that intimate moment
to so that people would understand like
if I can do it
and you're free to do it but you know
you need to do what you can do it to you
yeah but it with almost forced in this
we're kinda hard to come by all buy it
when he said yeah I'm really unrealistic
just no one's gonna be
that excited that happy to go through
this process i feel like im sure showed
both sides right
course you know she I'm not saying she
got pregnant I'm not going I just think
she got pregnant
to do this video but obviously her
allegiances are where they are because
working out there so she wanted to spend
it in a in a certain way
what do you guys make above the main
basically that
try to tell you what to do and because
it's pretty much all men or a huge
percentage Amanda
the Toros voting on abortion and Andy
Gray and allegedly writing a red
graduation all that and I'm always
fascinated by cuz I
literally cannot understand how someone
who does not have the body parts
can tell you what to do with your body
part
now totally greater need to be more
women in legislation so that kinda thing
doesn't happen
but I don't want to be too one-sided
because I feel like certain women who
are in relationships
have abortions without telling your
significant other and I can be
kinda gray area I think or you might
need to actually talk to the Father
I are you think they should have some
sort of like force you know I don't
think actually I don't think so but I
just feel like to say that you know men
have no say and they shouldn't even be
able to give me their opinion on it I
think that's going too far
yeah I mean of course I think men should
be able to give you their opinion
yeah we're talking with people that are
voting yeah I mean I'm back her sleep
feel very strongly that until the baby
is born
like it it a women's health issue and a
women's health issue
alone and Dylan this you know this
organism is a viable on its own what
we're all
really talking about is a medical
condition pregnancy is a medical
condition for a woman
yeah and it's a choice that she is
deciding to make the same way that you
can make a choice
about the best treatment option for her
cancer
the same way that you can make a choice
about a you know whether or not you want
to elect to have certain surgeries and
yes
I think that having outside perspectives
is helpful
I hope that if you're you're only lucky
enough to be in a situation where there
is a man in your life
yeah we the willing to give you his
opinion about the situation because
many times in a woman is faced with the
decision having an abortion she
on her fucking own and that even more
difficult but
it's her choice fundamentally it is her
choice and nobody has the right whether
we're talking about legislators
or we're talking about people with
personal relationships to tell a woman
what she can and can't do
with her own pregnancy because until
that baby is born
it is a women's health a medical issue
so you're saying
until that baby is born do you guys have
a cut-off is their cutoff point is that
the other debate you know is it the
two trimesters is it I didn't seem to me
that look if you were to say eight
months while that
baby probably could live it's silly to
draw a line to be honest
it but I think it's silly to draw a line
like obviously when the baby is born
then there are certain legal issues that
you can argue with right but before that
I feel like if an individual's
you know perspective on the situation
and that's why I'm pro-choice because my
opinion on that might not be a famous
somebody else's opinion that I recognize
that you know
I personally don't think I could go
through having an abortion but that has
nothing to do with my
you know willingness to vote on whether
not somebody else can you know I'm not
gonna be pushy
I mean obviously there are legal issues
that
you know in a perfect world we don't
often think about so sure maybe there's
a woman whose ate half months pregnant
she's abusing drugs and alcohol the
courts want to be able to say
right you're abusing a life inside a
view and we should be able to force you
to maybe
stop doing that we should be able to
force you to you have the child instead
Obama and that's where things start to
get really
touchy and really a you know touch you
go look at that but
I it if the complicated topic I think
but the problem
most of the time when it comes to this
kind of legislation
is not motivated by those specific
situations I think it legislation is
generally motivated by
religious bias and
a int there are people who go to the
extreme that they'll say that like the
actual
feed the actual Burma is you know
ordained by God and that that shouldn't
even be spilled so I I'm pretty sure my
yeah I bet the whole other topic
i buy two final thought on it is this
you know I was thinking
this putting this type of thing on
YouTube really such a 2014
thing is there something very freeing
happening in the digital
year that we can put this about their
that whether it's whether it's good or
bad weather we watch this and whether
it's strengthening the other side or not
or whether it's really affecting a
change anyone's mind
that can be more pro-choice this is all
good though just the information right
yeah I think that overall it a positive
thing just because it does give that
comfort to girls who've decided to have
an abortion but
I do see how it can really be a
lightning rod for the opposite side
yeah and that's what frustrates me the
most because religious people are the
ones who are saying
don't masturbate don't use condoms don't
take birth control and then they wanna
legislate against abortions it's like
well maybe if you are a little bit more
open minded about
prevention it's very cool that we're
living in a world right now
where free speech is and
is kinda helped by multimedia
and by the fact that the weekend you
something as simple as
the the camera on your phone to produce
a video in to tell a message in a much
more compelling way
than just standing outside and hoping
that people gather around us to hear
what we have to say
and we at least have that the money
internet for a little while longer
although
net neutrality was struck down with
we've also talked about a thousand times
so you know good luck to us all